le mot de la semaine a été prononcé par
le président sortant candidat à sa
réélection Emmanuel Macron
vous ne parlez pas à d'autres dirigeants
vous parlez votre banquier quand vous
parlez de la Russie
cette punchline a bien sûr été préparé
en amont ses équipes d'ailleurs n'en
n'avaient pas fait mystère plusieurs
fuites dans la presse indiquaient qu'il
allait attaquer Marine Le Pen sur sa
proximité avec Vladimir Poutine et le
sujet de son prêt contracté en 2014
auprès d'une banque proche du Kremlin
était idéale l'objectif d'Emmanuel
Macron c'était de démasquer Marine Le
Pen sur sa politique internationale sa
proximité avec les démocraties dites
illibérales comme la Hongrie de Victor
Orban mais aussi le soutien qu'elle a
apporté à Vladimir Poutine lors de
l'annexion de la Crimée en 2014 car si
la guerre en Ukraine a percuté la
campagne présidentielle elle s'est
inscrite dans les préoccupations des
Français et peut servir d'arguments
massues contre Marine Le Pen elle a
rétorqué dans son style vague avec le
registre de l'émotion en se servant de
la réputation du président sortant le
Mozart de la finance c'est comme ça que
on vous avait présenté je dis pas que
vous vous étiez présenté mais on vous
avait présenté à un bilan économique qui
est très mauvais mais le lendemain c'est
bien la punchline d'Emmanuel Macron que
les médias ont retenu pour lui c'est
gagné car son objectif premier était
caché secret il voulait absolument
qu'une de ces phrases soit retenue en
2017 il avait été déçu que ce soit
uniquement le délire de Marine Le Pen
autour des envahisseurs qui restent il
voulait donc marquer l'histoire c'est
certainement gagné le banquier de Marine
Le Pen devrait s'inscrire dans le
répertoire des formules cultes des
formules chocs comme le mois président
de François Hollande ou encore un peu
plus loin le monopole du cœur de Valéry
Giscard d'Estaing où l'homme du passif
de François Mitterrand